Let's go to Theresa from Austria.
Theresa, what is going on there?
Hi, dear. Can you hear me?
I can't. I think we had a
problem connecting last time you called in, but
now you're coming in crystal clear, as I was.
I'm usually not a Dischord user,
and I just downloaded it for the
vice presidential election. Right. So is.
Yeah, I actually pretty much wanted to give
you guys a heads up. I'm really nervous
for you when it comes to the election.
And actually, I wanted to ask, do you see an end
for the Electoral College at any given point?
Because I feel like I'm due to the Electoral
College. The whole idea of democracy is kind of at
risk. Yemen is really susceptible for corruption.
And I think. And Tony Barrett is very corrupt. I
think the whole Trump administration is, to be
frank of. In my opinion, Prince is just a robot
or a puppet to trauma. So from an outstanding
point, it looks really bad. What's going on?
Yeah, well, listen, that what
you're the Republican Party
wins elections because of the Electoral College.
So they don't want to get rid of it. If we had
popular vote in the United States, we would have
had fewer Republican presidents. So the Republican
Party is going to fight to the death to keep
the Electoral College. I think the best chance
to get rid of it is through something called the
National Popular Vote Interstate Compact. I won't
go into it now, but it's basically if enough
states decide to go popular vote in terms of
awarding their electoral electoral votes, you de
facto have a national popular vote. But I think
that it will be very difficult to get rid of
the Electoral College any other way. Even that
way it will be difficult. But we should get rid
of it. It is outdated and it is anti-democratic.
Yeah. And we're allowed to vote with 16 years of
age in Austria. So I think that would actually
turn around this election a lot because
I feel like the very young voters,
you know, would have such a big outcome in
this election or in any election, actually.
I agree with you, Theresa.
What part of Austria are you in?
I live in Lower Alstrom, actually,
just like 20 minutes away from Vienna.
OK, I was scheduled to be in Austria in
August this past August. There's a beautiful
new nonstop flight from Boston to Vienna, which
has now been canceled because of the virus. It all
exploded. But I was going to be in Vienna. I was
going to be in Salzburg. I was so looking forward
to it. It didn't have to be some other time.
I love Boston, too. I was an au pair Massachusetts
sexually. No, no. And I loved it. It's far
more European than what I would have thought.
Absolutely. Absolutely. That's especially what
we say to Texans. We're very European in Boston.
And they they just think we're assholes, you
know? All right. Thank you, sir. Thank you so
much. Great to hear from you.
Thank you for taking my call.
My pleasure. All right. Teresa from
Austria, what a day. What a day.